centaines de pompiers français arrivent
à Roberval ce matin les nouvelles
matinales n'ont rien de réjouissante le
nord du Québec ne dérougit pas
possible de circuler librement ici vous
allez voir la mairesse
la ville de Chapet est complètement
isolée la bourgade de 1500 personnes est
situé entre chibougamo à l'est et le Bel
sur Quevillon à l'ouest toutes deux
évacuer
la mairesse Isabelle Lessard et son
équipe s'activent pour répondre aux
besoins de sa population
Chapet qui dépend normalement des villes
voisines pour une foule de service se
trouve maintenant le baccalop de voir
faire venir la marchandise
en considérant que les routes sont
techniquement bloquées actuellement
malgré le fait que nous on n'est pas
évacué mais que tout le reste il est
c'est particulier la ville et sous ordre
d'évacuation volontaire deux tiers des
résidents ont décidé de partir les
autres restent même si la municipalité
est toujours entre deux feux
un Honor celui qui mène à chibougamo et
qui s'est en lentement mais doucement
par ici et un autre maîtriser au sud on
est au sud de la municipalité du Chapet
pouvez voir que les flammes étaient dans
ce boisé ici le boisé est à moitié
calcinée et la maison la plus proche et
de l'autre côté à moins de 100 mètres
et ont battu les arbres ils ont tout
pilé après ça les piles mécaniques
reviraient le sol des efforts herculés
ont été déployés par les soldats du feu
comme David Lanciaux pour protéger la
ville lorsqu'on entend c'est quoi on
entend la pompe de la soif qui est au
lac qui emmène l'eau où l'on peut voir
le boyau qui traverse ici dans le chemin
qui monte l'eau aux équipes en forêt une
pompe qui fonctionne 24 heures sur 24
pour alimenter les pompiers qui tentent
encore des timbres la moindre étincelle
avez-vous eu chaud
oui c'est sûr que fait chaud
[Musique]
utilise les médias sociaux pour garder
sa population est formée et aussi
longtemps que le feu se repose au
minimum ou contenu ça va être difficile
de dire que on est en sécurité
même si elle est à bout de souffle du
haut de ses 23 ans Isabelle
jusqu'au bout je suis même plus à me
demander est-ce que je suis est-ce que
je suis correct est-ce que je suis
capable c'est il faut que je sois
correct il faut que je sois capable
parce que 1500 personnes se fit sur moi
tenir jusqu'au bout en éteignant un feu
à la fois ici Elisa serrer Radio-Canada
Chapet